Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. On the morning of the 29th of April 1975, Keys Beach, who was a reporter for the Chicago Daily News, he was 61 years old, he had served in the Marines, was having breakfast with a group of other journalists when he was told that he had to get on a bus and head urgently and directly for Saigon's main airport. As they were heading there, however, news came in on the intercom that there were going to be no planes leaving from the airport. And so they turned around and they headed for the US embassy in Saigon. And he wrote, Beach wrote an incredible account of what he saw when he got there. Great
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。1975年4月29日清晨，61岁的基斯·比奇（Keys Beach）是《芝加哥每日新闻》的一名记者，他曾服役于美国海军陆战队。当时他正和一群记者一起吃早餐，突然被告知必须立刻登上大巴，紧急且直接地赶往西贡的主要机场。然而，在他们前往机场的途中，对讲机里传来了消息：机场将没有飞机起飞。于是他们调转车头，驶向了美国驻西贡大使馆。他写道——比奇对到达那里时的所见所闻进行了难以置信的记述。太棒了
seething mass of Vietnamese people trying to get over the walls of the US embassy compound. Once we moved into that seething mass, Beach wrote, we ceased to be correspondents. We were only men fighting for their lives, scratching, clawing, pushing ever closer to that wall. We were like animals. Now I thought, I know what it's like to be a Vietnamese. I am one of them. But if I could get over that wall, I would be an American again. My attaché case accidentally struck a baby in its mother's arms and its father beat at me with his fists. I tried to apologize as he kept on beating me while his wife pleaded with me to take the baby. Suddenly my arm was free and I edged closer to the wall. There were a pair of Marines on the wall. They were trying to help us up and kick the Vietnamese
乌歌般汹涌的越南人试图翻越美国大使馆大院的围墙。比奇写道，一旦我们挤进那汹涌的人群中，我们便不再是记者。我们只是为了生存而战的男人，抓挠、用指甲抠、推挤着，拼命向那堵墙靠近。我们就像动物一样。当时我想，我知道当一个越南人是什么感觉了。我就是他们中的一员。但如果我能翻过那堵墙，我又会是一个美国人了。我的公文包不小心击中了母亲怀里的婴儿，孩子的父亲挥起拳头打我。我一边试图道歉，他一边继续殴打我，而他的妻子则恳求我带走这个孩子。突然，我的手臂解放了，我向墙边挪了挪。墙上有两名海军陆战队员。他们试图把我们拉上去，并把越南人
down. One of them looked down at me. Help me, I pleaded. Please help me. That Marine did help me. He reached down with his long muscular arm and pulled me up as if I were a helpless child. I lay on a tin roof, gasping for breath like a landed fish, then dropped to the ground. God bless the Marines. I was one myself in the last of the just wars. So Dominic, this is from the chapter you wrote in your sadly edited book. So this chapter never made it out, but it's a brilliant, brilliant chapter describing the fall of Saigon. We come to the end game, 29th of April, and the evacuation is famously flagged up for those in the know, isn't it? By the playing of White Christmas.
踹下去。其中一人低头看着我。我哀求道，救救我。请救救我。那个海军陆战队员真的救了我。他伸出肌肉发达的长臂，把我拉了上去，就像拉起一个无助的孩子。我躺在铁皮屋顶上，像一条被钓上岸的鱼一样大口喘着粗气，然后掉到了地上。上帝保佑海军陆战队员。在最后一场正义的战争中，我自己也曾是一名海军陆战队员。所以，多米尼克，这段话出自你那本惨遭删减的书中的章节。所以这个章节从未问世，但这是一篇极其精彩的章节，描述了西贡的陷落。我们迎来了终局，4月29日，知情人士都知道，撤离行动有一个著名的暗号，对吧？通过播放《白色圣诞节》。
Yeah. By Armed Forces Radio. You're not going to see it. I'm not. I can just see you gearing up. What I was gearing up to say was a detail that I'd seen on the Ken Burns documentary about this, that in fact, it wasn't the Bing Crosby version, even though it was meant to be.
是的。通过武装部队广播电台。你不会看到的。我不会。我只看到你已经跃跃欲试了。我想说的是我在肯·伯恩斯的纪录片里看到的一个细节：事实上，那并不是宾·克 Crosby（Bing Crosby）的版本，尽管本该如此。
They couldn't find the record. So they had to put out some other version of it. Anyway, that's as may be. The signal has been given. It's time for Americans to leave, but not for Vietnamese. With the consequence, it is very, very dramatically and tragically illustrated by that account that I just read. Yeah, it's an extraordinary scene. So in the last podcast, Tom, we were talking, weren't we, about how you get from Henry Kissinger and Le Dudocto signing the peace agreement in January 1973, winning the Nobel Peace Prize, and then getting from there to the end of April 1975,
他们找不到那张唱片了。所以他们不得不播放其他版本。总之，不管怎样。信号已经发出。美国人是时候离开了，但越南人不是。其结果正如我刚才读到的那段记述所生动、悲惨地说明的那样。是的，这是一个非同寻常的场景。所以在上一期播客中，汤姆，我们讨论过，不是吗？关于亨利·基辛格和黎德寿在1973年1月签署和平协定、赢得诺贝尔和平奖，然后如何走到1975年4月底这一步的，
the South Vietnamese regime collapsing, this country in which the Americans have invested so much time, money, blood, effort, intellectual and moral capital on the verge of collapse. And we ended last time by talking about the disjuncture between the White House, which is saying, get everything ready, get out. We need to do this as quickly and efficiently as possible. That's Gerald Ford and Henry Kissinger and Ambassador Graham Martin, who has refused really to make preparations because he says that will spark panic in Saigon and be a betrayal of the Vietnamese. We also talked, didn't we, about how there are 6,000 Americans, but there are up to a million Vietnamese who have a reasonable expectation
南越政权土崩瓦解，这个美国投入了如此多的时间、金钱、鲜血、心血、知识和道德资本的国家正处于崩溃的边缘。我们在上一期结束时讨论了白宫的表态与实际情况之间的脱节，白宫一直在说：做好一切准备，撤离。我们需要尽可能快、尽可能高效地完成这件事。那是杰拉尔德·福特、亨利·基辛格和大使格雷厄姆·马丁（Graham Martin），后者一直拒绝真正做准备，因为他说这会在西贡引发恐慌，是对越南人的背叛。我们还讨论过，不是吗？有6000名美国人，但有多达100万越南人对被撤离抱有合理的期望。
that they're going to be taken out. So as you said, Armed Forces Radio played the song White Christmas. That's about 11 o'clock on the 29th of April. The North Vietnamese final offensive has been underway since dawn. General Dzung, who is the North Vietnamese commander, has been given the instruction to strike into the enemy's final lair, which is a very 1970s communist. Is that the US embassy or the presidential palace? The presidential palace is where they're really heading for. I mean's the that's the target but the u.s embassy obviously is vulnerable um people are already starting to to sort of assemble outside the u.s embassy that that warning say what's white christmas the playing of the song and then the announcer says the words it is 105 degrees in saigon and
正如你所说，武装部队广播电台播放了歌曲《白色圣诞节》。那是4月29日大约11点。北越的最后攻势从黎明就开始了。北越指挥官邓将军（General Dzung）接到了指令，要直捣敌人的最后老巢，这非常具有20世纪70年代的共产主义风格。那是美国大使馆还是总统府？总统府才是他们真正前进的目标。我的意思是，那是目标，但美国大使馆显然很脆弱，呃，人们已经开始聚集在美国大使馆外面了。那个警告说，什么是《白色圣诞节》，播放这首歌，然后播音员说出了这样的话：西贡气温105华氏度，且
rising and that is the cue that all the Americans have been told, get to the embassy. You must get to the embassy. So Dominic, a question at this point, what if they hadn't? What if they'd relied on their diplomatic community? Would there have been a kind of Tehran in 1979 situation? That is an excellent question, Tom. And the truth of the matter is we don't know because they did get out, most of them. But say, for example, you started the last episode by talking about the future Oxford professor of poetry, James Fenton. He hangs around. Well, not only did that, he goes to the US embassy and loots stuff, doesn't he? At some point? Yes. He's there in the ruins with loads of other people kind of peeking through the bookshelves.
还在上升。这就是给所有美国人的暗号：去大使馆。你们必须去大使馆。那么，多米尼克，此时有一个问题，如果他们没有去呢？如果他们依靠外交界呢？会不会出现一种类似1979年德黑兰的情况？这是一个极好的问题，汤姆。事实的真相是，我们不知道，因为他们确实撤出来了，大多数人都是。但比方说，你上一期开头提到过，未来的牛津大学诗歌教授詹姆斯·芬顿（James Fenton）。他留了下来。不仅如此，他还去了美国大使馆搜刮东西，对吧？在某个时刻？是的。他和其他许多人在废墟里窥视书架。
But then he's British. I mean, he's not American. But I think the chances are actually that you would have been taking an enormous risk. No one knows. People at this point don't know that the North Vietnamese are not like the Khmer Rouge. Yeah, okay. So there's an expectation you could easily be shot. I mean, the only sensible thing would be, what if you're cut off? You could be held hostage, Tom. You could end up in a prisoner of war camp.
但他是个英国人。我的意思是，他不是美国人。但我认为，实际上你当时是在冒着巨大的风险。没有人知道。此时的人们并不知道北越人不像红色高棉。好吧，所以人们会觉得你随时可能被枪毙。我的意思是，唯一明智的做法是……如果你被切断了退路呢？汤姆，你可能会被当成肉票。你可能会最终进战俘营。
You could be shot out of hand. Paraded on TV. Paraded on TV, Tom. You could end up in a prisoner of war camp. You could be shot out of hand. Paraded on TV. Paraded on TV. Exactly. So if you've got any sense at all, you're going to get yourself down to the embassy. So they've got huge Chinook helicopters. The US 7th Fleet is offshore in the South China Sea. So that's only about a half hour flight away. And isn't there, in the courtyard, there's a tamarind tree that has to be chopped down if the helicopter is going to land in it. And Martin is still reluctant to have it chopped down. That's right, yes.
你可能会直接被枪决。在电视上游街示众。在电视上游街示众，汤姆。你可能会最终进战俘营。你可能会直接被枪决。在电视上游街示众。在电视上游街示众。完全正确。所以只要你脑子还清醒，你就会去大使馆。那里有巨大的支奴干直升机。美国第七舰队正停泊在南海的离岸水域。那只有大约半小时的飞行时间。而且，在庭院里不是有一棵罗望子树吗？如果直升机要在那里降落，就必须把它砍掉。而马丁仍然不愿意砍掉它。没错，是的。
It gets chopped down in the end. last time about Henry Kissinger comparing him with General Gordon, the great British imperial martyr of the 19th century, killed by the Mardis forces in Khartoum. I think there is a slight sense of Ambassador Martin having a General Gordon complex and wanting to be the martyr. I don't think he wants to be speared on the steps of the embassy, but I think he wants to be the absolute last man out. He's reluctant to go. He feels this terrible sense of betrayal. Well, the American ambassador in Plompen had been the last out, hadn't he?
它最终还是被砍掉了。我们上一次谈到亨利·基辛格把他比作戈登将军（General Gordon），那是19世纪伟大的英国帝国烈士，在喀土穆被马赫迪军队杀死。我认为马丁大使多少有点“戈登将军情结”，想成为烈士。我不认为他想在大使馆台阶上被长矛刺死，但我认为他想成为最后一个离开的人。他不愿意离开。他有一种可怕的背叛感。好吧，金边（Plompen）的美国大使是最后一个离开的，对吧？
Yes, but he had walked out with a folded American flag. There'd be much smaller numbers and it'd be much more sort of decorous and efficient. I mean, to give you an example of the inefficiency, we are now, we are in sort of, let's say, mid-morning, the 29th of April. The communist tanks are rolling through the streets. Meanwhile, in the US embassy, there's like documents everywhere.
是的，但他手里折叠着一面美国国旗走了出去。人数要少得多，而且要体面和高效得多。我的意思是，举个低效的例子，我们现在，正处于4月29日上午左右。共产主义的坦克正在街上隆隆驶过。与此同时，在美国大使馆里，到处都是文件。
The secretaries are tottering under piles of shredding. So very fawn hall behavior from, if you remember from the Iran Contra podcast we did. Am I not right that this is a huge problem for the helicopters? Because shredded material can kind of get whipped up and get sucked into the... It's wafting through the air. Smoke is literally rising above the embassy because people are burning documents.
秘书们在成堆的碎纸机残渣中摇摇欲坠。这真是非常“发航大厦”（Fawn Hall）式的行为，如果你还记得我们做过的伊朗门播客的话。我没记错的话，这对直升机来说是个大问题吧？因为碎纸材料可能会被卷起并吸入……它们在空气中飘荡。浓烟正从大使馆上方升起，因为人们在焚烧文件。
And that is a problem for the helicopters. So it's all very chaotic. They've sent out embassy employees with lists of key people that they need to get out of the city. So there's a good example, a guy called Ken Moorfield. He's commandeered buses. He goes off to buildings in Saigon to pick up people who are waiting.
这对直升机来说是个大问题。所以这一切都非常混乱。他们派出了大使馆员工，手里拿着需要撤离出城的关键人物名单。这里有个很好的例子，一个叫肯·莫尔菲尔德（Ken Moorfield）的家伙。他征用了公共汽车。他前往西贡的各栋建筑去接那些等待的人。
And he tells the story. There's one building called the Brinks Building. So that's where senior American officers had stayed during the American kind of military occupation of Saigon. Moorfield gets there to pick up the people he wants, and there are hundreds of other people who he describes. And he says, they are intelligence agents. They are waiters.
他讲述了这样一个故事。有一栋建筑叫布林克斯大楼（Brinks Building）。那是美国对西贡进行军事占领期间，高级美国军官居住的地方。莫尔菲尔德去那里接他想要的人，结果那里有数百名他所描述的其他人员。他说，他们是情报人员。他们是服务生。
They are all people who have kind of been complicit, as it were, with the American presence. And they're just standing there looking at him. And he says to them, stand fast, stand fast. And he can't meet their eyes because he knows there's no- They're going to be betrayed. They're going to be betrayed. And they're just waiting expectantly with their briefcases and whatnot and their suitcases ready to go.
他们都是多多少少与美国存在共谋关系的人。他们就站在那里看着他。他对他们说：“坚守，坚守。”他不敢直视他们的眼睛，因为他知道没有……他们会被背叛的。他们将被背叛。他们只是带着公文包、随身物品和随时准备出发的手提箱，满怀期待地等待着。
And there's the beach story that you told. I mean, that is an amazing story. So Keys Beach, if you read the whole story which he wrote in the Chicago Daily News, they set off for the airport, a load of journalists. And as you said, they get turned away. But they're in this bus and there are crowds of vietnamese beating on the bus the whole time trying to be let aboard and beach describes he says you know there's people from cbs nbc all the rest of it who are normally like mild-mannered completely kind of pacific kind of guys who are literally beating back vietnamese civilians trying to say but all
还有你讲的比奇的故事。我的意思是，那是一个惊人的故事。所以基斯·比奇，如果你读完整篇他在《芝加哥每日新闻》上发表的文章，就会发现他们一帮记者出发去机场。正如你所说，他们被拒之门外。但他们坐在这辆大巴上，大巴外面挤满了捶打车门、拼命想挤上车的越南人，比奇描述说，CBS、NBC的所有那些人，平时都是温文尔雅、完全爱好和平的家伙，此刻却在字面意义上殴打那些试图上车的越南平民，然而……
the marines on the wall were kind of smashing people with the butts of their rifles they are exactly yes beating them in the face one of his colleagues bob tamarkin i think his name is who also wrote for the chicago daily news he describes people pointing their guns at the vietnamese and shouting get down you bastard or i'll blow your head off all this kind of thing so it's it is a horrendous scene it's actually i would say far more chaotic bloodier more more visceral than even what we saw in kabul in the fall of afghanistan to the taliban well i tell you what it reminds me of actually is um another british imperial, which is the withdrawal from Kabul. 1842. In 1842, which was kind of similarly supposed to be, you know, the plans had been laid and they all just fell to pieces.
墙上的海军陆战队员也用步枪托猛砸人们的面部，确实如此，是的，打他们的脸。他的同事之一鲍勃·塔马金（Bob Tamarkin，我没记错的话），也是《芝加哥每日新闻》的记者，他描述了人们用枪指着越南人并大喊“滚下去，混蛋，否则我轰了你的头”之类的话。所以这是一场可怕的场景。实际上，我认为它比我们在阿富汗政权崩溃、塔利班攻陷喀土穆时看到的场景还要混乱、血腥、更具本能冲击力。好吧，我告诉你这让我想起了什么，实际上是……另一个英国帝国事件，也就是喀土穆撤退。1842年。在1842年，当时也是计划得好好的，结果全部土崩瓦解。
I mean, in the event, it's better for the Americans because they do at least get the Americans out. Yes. All the British get slaughtered except for one doctor and flashman. Yeah, that's right. The sense in which these episodes kind of echo what had gone before in European imperial history is really interesting, I think. It is.
我的意思是，实际上，对美国人来说情况要好一些，因为他们至少把美国人撤出来了。是的。所有的英国人都被屠杀了，除了一个医生和弗拉什曼（Flashman）。是的，没错。这些事件在某种程度上呼应了欧洲帝国历史上的过去，这真的很有趣，我认为。确实如此。
As well as the way in which they prefigure what has happened in American history since Vietnam. It's always because they work as metaphors, don't they, for Western hubris, don't you think? Absolutely. And for the arrogance of industrialized modernity and of Western civility and all these kinds of things in the face of crisis, that everything collapses. So Keyes Beach, that bit you quoted, I always think it's such a revealing line. And I don't think he means this in a pejorative way.
以及它们预示了越南战争以来美国历史上面发生的事情的方式。它们总是能发挥作用，不是吗，作为西方傲慢的隐喻，你不觉得吗？绝对是的。而且面对危机时，工业化现代性和西方文明的傲慢等等一切都土崩瓦解了。所以基斯·比奇，你引用的那段话，我一直觉得是一句非常具有启示性的台词。我不认为他是以贬义的方式说这句话的。
I completely understand what he means, where he says, we were like animals. Now I thought, I know what it's like to be Vietnamese. I'm one of them, but if I could get over that wall, I would be an American again. And that sort of sense that the Americans have always thought of themselves as, I mean, frankly, they've always thought of themselves as superior to the Vietnamese. And suddenly in the face of the crisis, they've all been dragged back. But Dominic, I mean, legally, in the context of a city that's being invaded by people who want to kill everybody, that they might think they are superior because Americans have a legal right to get out. Yeah.
我完全理解他的意思，他说：“我们就像动物一样。现在我想，我知道当一个越南人是什么感觉了。我就是他们中的一员，但如果我能翻过那堵墙，我又会是一个美国人了。”这种感觉——美国人一直认为自己是……坦白说，他们一直认为自己高于越南人。突然间面对危机，他们都被拉回了现实。但多米尼克，我的意思是，从法律上讲，在一个遭到想要杀死所有人的侵略者入侵的城市背景下，他们可能会认为自己更优越，因为美国人有合法撤离的权利。是的。
Well, isn't that what he means? Yes. Of course, what he means is that if I'm on that side of the wall, I'm an American and I can get on a helicopter. If I'm stuck on this side of the wall, I'm just one of them. Yeah. And I could end up in front of a firing squad or anything. I mean, this is obviously what's in the minds of Henry Kissinger and the people back in Washington who are saying, all the Americans must be on this side of the wall,
难道这不正是他的意思吗？是的。当然，他的意思是，如果我在墙的那一边，我就是美国人，我就可以登上直升机。如果我被困在墙的这一边，我就是他们中的一员。是的。我可能会被拉去枪决或者遭遇别的什么。我的意思是，这显然是亨利·基辛格和华盛顿那些人的想法：所有美国人必须都在墙的这一边，
inside the embassy compound, and nobody else is to be let in. And actually, what you get a sense of when you go through the story is that in the White House or in Washington, Kissinger, Ford, all these people are saying, what's going on over there? Because they have no sense of the scale of the catastrophe that is unfolding. And they are also doing it all through an ambassador who's being forced to do it against his will. So you talked about his General Gordon complex. I mean, how did the American, I guess the president, Kissinger, whoever, how do they get Martin out of the embassy and get everybody else out of the embassy? Well, the crazy thing is, Tom, that at 10 o'clock that night, he is still there. The helicopter has been taking off all afternoon.
在大使馆大院内部，绝对不许任何人再进来。事实上，当你通读这个故事时，你会有一种感觉：在白宫或华盛顿，基辛格、福特所有这些人都在问：“那边到底在搞什么鬼？”因为他们根本没有意识到正在上演的灾难的规模。而且他们的一切行动都必须通过一个违背其意愿的大使来进行。所以你谈到了他的戈登将军情结。我的意思是，美国人——我想是总统、基辛格或其他什么人——是怎么把马丁弄出大使馆，并把其他人也弄出大使馆的呢？好吧，疯狂的是，汤姆，当晚10点，他还在那里。直升机整个下午都在起飞。
Ambassador Martin is still there. Washington sends him a demand at 10 o'clock that night saying, all repeat, all Americans must now be evacuated. He is still refusing to go. It's absolutely mind boggling. He sends back a message that reads as follows. Perhaps you can tell me how to make some of these Americans abandon their half Vietnamese children or how the president would look if he ordered this. So basically what they do is at midnight, the Marines order that everybody now must withdraw into an inner compound inside the embassy. So you imagine the embassy is a series of kind of compounds within compounds. So they've gone through to the inner compound.
马丁大使仍然在那里。华盛顿在当晚10点向他发出了最后通牒，称所有美国人——再次强调，所有美国人——现在必须全部撤离。他仍然拒绝离开。这简直令人匪夷所思。他回传了一条电报，内容如下：“也许你能告诉我，如何让其中一些美国人抛弃他们半越南血统的孩子，或者如果总统下达这样的命令，他会作何感想。”所以基本上他们的做法是：在午夜时分，海军陆战队员下令所有人现在必须撤退到大使馆内部的一个内院。所以你可以想象，大使馆是一系列大院套着大院。所以他们已经退到了内院。
And at three o'clock that morning, so the helicopters are landing all the time on the roof. At three o'clock that morning, Washington sends a message to say there are going to be 19 more helicopters and Ambassador Martin must be on one of the helicopters. The last one is their expectation. But what's happening is the helicopters are landing. You said the tree had been cut down. They're landing in the kind of car park of the embassy. But all the time, because the embassy is under siege from this mob of people
当天凌晨3点，直升机一直在屋顶降落。当天凌晨3点，华盛顿发来消息称，还将有19架直升机抵达，马丁大使必须登上其中一架。他们的预期是最后一架。但实际情况是直升机正在降落。你刚才说树已经被砍掉了。它们正降落在大使馆的停车场里。但由于大使馆一直被这群暴民围攻，
the car park is actually no longer safe for them to land the helicopters so they say we can only now use the embassy roof which means they have to use smaller helicopters so they can't get all the people that they've said they think they can get out even that small number of people so there are hundreds of Vietnamese who have got through some of these sort of walls. Checks and things. Checks, who are clearly not going to be got out. I mean, that's the absolutely terrifying thing. So about four o'clock in the morning, the commander of the Marines is a man called Major Jim Keane. He gets a message and the message says, you get Ambassador Martin on the next helicopter now. And he's
停车场实际上已经不再安全，无法让直升机降落了，所以他们说现在只能使用大使馆屋顶，这意味着他们必须使用更小的直升机，因此他们无法像预期的那样运走所有人，甚至连原本预期的一小部分人都无法运走。所以有数百名越南人已经冲破了部分围墙。支票之类的。支票，显然是撤不出去了。我的意思是，这绝对是极其恐怖的事情。所以在凌晨四点左右，海军陆战队的指挥官是一个叫吉姆·基恩少校（Major Jim Keane）的人。他收到了一条消息，消息说：“你现在就把马丁大使弄上下一架直升机。”而他
actually under orders that if martin resists they basically have to arrest him and put him on the helicopter at the point of a gun isn't it true that um that when he's being taken up you know up to the top of the roof the marines guarding the access point one of them is reading a book about the fall of rome yeah what an amazing detail that is so the marines are kind of slumped on the floor now. They're surrounded by all their kit. They've got their guns, they've got their packs, and they're going to be the last to go. And as Martin passes, yes, exactly, one of the journalists notices that he's reading a battered paperback that's called The Fall of Rome. About five o'clock in the morning, Martin is put onto
实际上接到的命令是，如果马丁抗命，他们基本上必须逮捕他，并用枪指着把他押上直升机。难道不是吗？当他被带往顶部屋顶时，守卫通道的海军陆战队员中，有一个人正在读一本关于罗马帝国衰亡的书，对吧？这是一个多么惊人的细节啊！所以海军陆战队员现在有点瘫坐在地板上。他们被所有的装备包围着。他们拿着枪，背着背包，他们将是最后一批离开的人。当马丁走过时，是的，完全没错，一个记者注意到他正在读一本破旧平装书，书名叫《罗马帝国衰亡史》。大约凌晨五点，马丁被送上了一架
a helicopter called the Lady 809. And he's the last official American representative in South Vietnam. And off the helicopter goes and it takes him towards the 7th Fleet, which is out in the South China Sea. However, he's the last sort of official representative, but there are still Americans because there are still Marines. And now the situation is that the Marines all the time, there are vietnamese that are now down there in the car park beginning to make their way up through the embassy towards the roof where the marines are now stationed and it's basically a race against time for the helicopters to get the
名为“809号贵妇”（Lady 809）的直升机。他是南越最后一个官方美国代表。直升机起飞了，载着他飞向停泊在南海的第七舰队。然而，他是最后一个官方代表，但仍然有美国人，因为海军陆战队员还在。现在的局势是，源源不断的越南人现在已经涌进停车场，开始穿过大使馆，向海军陆战队员驻守的屋顶进发，这基本上是一场直升机在越南人赶到之前抢运海军陆战队员的生死时速。这就像一部丧尸电影，不是吗？确实是这样，你知道的，人们被困在购物中心顶上，周围都是丧尸，等待救援。
marines before the vietnamese get there it's like a kind of zombie film isn't it it is actually you know it's people stuck on the top of a shopping centre surrounded by zombies waiting to be taken off. It is, and that's a terrible thing to say because it sort of plays into that sort of sense that the Vietnamese are a threat because that's certainly how they're seen at this point, that it's such chaos and all sort of civility
是的，这是一个可怕的比喻，因为它有点助长了那种认为越南人是威胁的看法，因为当时他们确实被这样看待——场面如此混乱，所有的文明礼貌
has been cast to the winds. But, of course, the Vietnamese are people who have worked with the Americans for years, decades, who have got all their stuff, who are terrified, and will have been promised. They've been promised that helicopters are coming. And Major Keane, he knows that there are about 100 Marines left. There are just enough spaces on the helicopters for them, but for nobody else. So at about 5.30, he tells his men, everybody up now,
都被抛到了九霄云外。但是，当然，越南人是那些与美国人共事多年、数十年的平民，他们带上了所有的家当，惊恐万状，而且曾得到过承诺。他们被承诺过直升机回来接他们。基恩少校知道还剩大约100名海军陆战队员。直升机上的空间只够装他们，再也容不下任何人了。所以在5点半左右，他对部下说：“所有人现在起立，
we bar the doors. And they actually jam things like air conditioning units in the doorways to block the Vietnamese from getting onto the roof. And that really is, you know, you said like a zombie film. That is the kind of atmosphere. But by now, the Vietnamese have kind of twigged what's happening, right? Yeah. So some of them are going mad. And so you say that they're busy urinating gleefully in the swimming pool. Well, I don't know if gleefully is the right word. I mean, to some extent, some of them have yielded to a kind of...
我们把门封死。”他们甚至把空调机之类的东西塞进门缝里，以阻止越南人冲上屋顶。这真的是，你刚才说像丧尸电影，这就是那种氛围。但到这时，越南人已经琢磨出发生什么事了吧？是的。所以其中一些人气疯了。你甚至提到他们在游泳池里兴高采烈地小便。嗯，我不知道“兴高采烈”是不是合适的词。我的意思是，在某种程度上，他们中的一些人陷入了一种……
Macabre carnival, you say. Do I say that? You say, from the roof, Major Keane's men could see them stripping the restaurant of its fittings, carrying off frozen steaks and slabs of ribs, cartons of cigarettes, playing bumper cars with abandoned embassy vehicles, urinating gleefully in the swimming pool, cavorting in one last macabre carnival. Crikey.
你称之为“毛骨悚然的狂欢”。我这么说过吗？你写道：“从屋顶上，基恩少校的手下可以看到他们正在剥离餐厅的设施，搬走冷冻牛排和排骨、一箱箱的香烟，开着被遗弃的大使馆车辆玩碰碰车，在游泳池里兴高采烈地小便，在最后一场毛骨悚然的狂欢中嬉戏。”天哪。
Macabre carnival is a quote though, so somebody else must have said that. Yes, this is all description from the time. Yeah, Major Keane. So he's one of these people who later gave loads and loads of interviews about it. So the helicopters keep coming. By about 7, 7.30, there's just one group left 11 marines and then as
不过“毛骨悚然的狂欢”是个引语，所以肯定有别人这么说过。是的，这些都是当时的描述。是的，基恩少校。所以他是后来就此接受了大量采访的人之一。所以直升机源源不断地飞来。到了7点、7点半左右，只剩下一组人了——11名海军陆战队员——然后正如
you'll remember from the ken burns documentary that you were saying last time you'd watch tom there's then a delay before the final helicopter comes so picture the scene dawn is breaking or has broken over saigon a lot of the city is on fire, smoke over the city. There are North Vietnamese troops advancing through the city towards the presidential palace. There's the mob below in the embassy. There are mobs on the streets. These 11 guys, US Marines, are on the top of the embassy and they are waiting. They are exhausted. There are various points where people are starting to smash through the windows of the doors onto the embassy roof, and they're having to beat them back or spray them with mace. And they've lost their walkie-talkies, haven't they?
你从肯·伯恩斯的纪录片里记起的那样，你上一次看过的，汤姆，最后一架直升机到来之前有一段延迟——想象一下当时的场景：黎明正在西贡破晓或已经破晓，城市的许多地方都在燃烧，城上空黑烟滚滚。北越军队正穿过城市向总统府推进。大使馆下面挤满了暴民。街上也挤满了暴民。这11名美国海军陆战队员正站在大使馆顶上等待着。他们筋疲力尽。好几次，人们开始砸碎通往大使馆屋顶的门窗，他们不得不将其击退或用梅斯毒气（mace）喷射他们。他们的对讲机也丢了，对吧？
So they have no way of communicating. So they don't know if the helicopters are coming for them. And then they're waiting and waiting and waiting. And of course, they think if no helicopter comes, we'll either be lynched by the people in the embassy or we'll be captured by the communists, paraded on TV or shot or who knows. No good option. And they're waiting and waiting. And then basically at 7.53, I think it is, they see one last kind of black dot against the sky, one last helicopter coming back for them. They get aboard the helicopter. And back for them they get aboard the helicopter and the last you know the last thing they do as the helicopter takes off i mean it says so much
所以他们无法与外界沟通。因此他们根本不知道直升机是否会来接他们。然后他们就在那儿等啊等啊等。当然，他们心想，如果没有直升机来，我们要麽在大使馆里被暴民私刑处死，要麽被共产党抓获，在电视上游街示众，或者被枪决，谁知道呢。没有好下场。他们就在那儿等啊等。然后在7点53分左右，我想是这个时间，他们看到天空中出现了一个最后的黑点——最后一架回来接他们的直升机。他们登上了直升机。
about the american commitment to vietnam the last thing they do before leaving is they throw their tear gas grenades over the side trying to deter the looters and then they lift off into the sky and they're gone it's amazing isn't it because actually helicopters beating through early morning haze is absolutely the image that kind of dominates the folk tales of Vietnam because of Apocalypse Now and because of this. And they blur. So the helicopters in Apocalypse Now are, you know, Ride of the Valkyries destroying, and here they're scuttling and withdrawing. Yes. The chopper had been the sort of the emblematic military technology of the Vietnam War.
他们登上了直升机，你知道的，随着直升机起飞，他们做的最后一件事——这充分说明了美国对越南的承诺——他们离开前做的最后一件事是把催泪瓦斯手榴弹扔过栏杆，试图阻止抢劫者，然后他们升空离去了。这太神奇了，不是吗？因为事实上，直升机划破清晨薄雾的轰鸣声绝对是主宰越南民间传说的标志性意象，因为《现代启示录》（Apocalypse Now），也因为这一幕。它们交织在了一起。所以《现代启示录》中的直升机是《女武神的骑行》带来的毁灭，而这里的直升机则是狼狈逃窜和撤离。是的。直升机一直是越南战争最具象征意义的军事技术。
And so it's almost like a sort of script writer. Yeah. So the beating of the fan kind of blurring into the sound of helicopters moving. I mean, it's kind of, if I shut my eyes and think of Vietnam, that's basically the sound that I hear. Yeah. That and the music of the doors from Apocalypse Now. This is the end.
所以它几乎就像是编剧写好的剧本一样。是的。因此，旋翼的拍打声逐渐融入了直升机移动的声音中。我的意思是，如果我闭上眼睛去想越南，这基本上就是我听到的声音。是的。还有《现代启示录》里门乐队（The Doors）的音乐。这是末日。
Those things all being one sort of almost psychedelic kind of trance-like. Yeah. And the fact that they go with helicopters. But actually, of course, the story doesn't quite end there, at least not for those guys, because they're brought back to the ships. And actually, when you read about, they get off the choppers, and a lot of them are in tears. Bob Tamarkin, who we mentioned the journalist he's
这些东西全都融合成了一种几乎是迷幻般的、出神入化的状态。是的。而且他们是乘直升机离开的。但事实上，故事当然并没有就此结束，至少对那些人来说没有，因为他们被带回了军舰上。事实上，当你读到他们走下直升机时的情景时，许多人都泪流满面。我们之前提到的记者鲍勃·塔马金，他
sitting on a bunk next to a guy called stewart harrington who is a u.s intelligence officer and stewart harrington says they lied to us at the very end they promised they promised i've never received an order in my life to do something i was ashamed of if i'd known how it's going to end i'd refuse the order and then um and a lieutenant colonel lieutenant colonel i suppose he'd have called himself um butts in and he says to tamarkin do you know what you saw do you really know what you saw the reporter says i saw the evacuation of the u.s embassy in the last hours and this guy says no you saw deceit you saw how he let this country down to the very end so they're absolutely the people who've done who've been involved with this,
正坐在一个铺位旁，旁边是一个叫斯图尔特·哈林顿（Stuart Harrington）的美国情报军官。斯图尔特·哈林顿说：“他们在最后关头对我们撒了谎。他们许过诺，他们许过诺。我这辈子从来没有接到过让我感到羞耻的命令。如果我知道会是这个结局，我会拒绝执行这个命令。”然后呢……一个中校——我想他会自称为中校——插话对塔马金说：“你知道你刚才看到的是什么吗？你真的知道你看到的是什么吗？”记者说：“我看到了美军大使馆在最后时刻的撤离。”而这家伙说：“不，你看到的是背叛。你看到了他们是如何直到最后一刻将这个国家抛弃的。”所以那些亲历并参与此事的人，
they are absolutely wracked by guilt at what has happened. Meanwhile, the North Vietnamese crash through the gates into the presidential palace. I know you were very entertained, Tom, when we were texting each other about this, that the last leader of South Vietnam was called Big Minh.
内心绝对被发生的事情带来的罪恶感折磨得千疮百孔。与此同时，北越军队冲破大门，闯入了总统府。我知道当你和我发短信讨论这件事时，汤姆，你觉得南越的最后一个领导人叫“大明”（Big Minh）非常搞笑。
It's a good name. It is a good name. Big Minh. So I'll tell Vietnam was called Big Min. It's a good name. It is a good name. You know, Big Min. So I'll tell you something about Big Min. It's like something from Damon Runyon. It is. It is. He's a very Damon Runyon-like character because Big Min,
这是个好名字。这确实是个好名字。大明。所以我要告诉你……南越的最后一个领导人叫大明。这真是个好名字。这确实是个好名字。你知道的，“大明”。所以我得告诉你关于大明的事。这就像达蒙·鲁尼恩（Damon Runyon）小说里的角色。确实如此。他非常有达蒙·鲁尼恩笔下那种角色的特点，因为大明，
he'd had a couple of goes at being the kind of strongman of South Vietnam, and he'd ended up kind of, you know, the music stopped and he was in the chair. He only had one tooth because all the rest of them had been pulled out by the Japanese in the Second World War. Oh, God. But when he smiled, apparently, he would smile in a way to exhibit his single tooth to sort of remind you of his courage. Yeah. So Big Min is waiting for the North Vietnamese.
他曾当过几次南越的强人，结果呢……音乐停了，而他正坐在椅子上。他只有一颗牙齿，因为其余的都在二战中被日本人拔掉了。哦，天哪。但显然，当他微笑时，他会以一种展示他那唯一一颗牙齿的方式微笑，以此来提醒人们他的勇气。所以大明正在等待北越军队。
The Americans have just gone. The North Vietnamese arrived. And he says, I'm here to surrender power to you. And they say, well The Americans have just gone. The North Vietnamese arrived. And he says, I'm here to surrender power to you. And they say, well, you have no power. You know, there's nothing to surrender. There's no question
美国人刚刚离开。北越军队抵达了。他说：“我是来向你们移交权力的。”而他们说：“呃……”美国人刚刚离开。北越军队抵达了。他说：“我是来向你们移交权力的。”而他们说：“呃，你根本没有权力。你知道的，根本没有什么权力好移交。根本不存在
of you transferring power. Then there's somebody who shoots those guns outside and Big Min and his ministers all kind of quail. And the North Vietnamese say, oh, don't worry. You have nothing to fear.
你向我们移交权力的问题。”这时外面有人开枪了，大明和他的部长们都有点吓得发抖。北越人说：“哦，别担心。你们没什么好害怕的。
This is a moment of joy for our country, all this kind of thing. And Big Min and his guys relax. And the captain or whatever says to Big Min, how's your orchid collection? Big Min was a big orchid collector. Was he? Oh.
这是我们国家欢乐的时刻，诸如此类的话。”大明和他的手下放松了下来。那个上尉还是什么人对大明说：“你的兰花收集得怎么样了？”大明是一个狂热的兰花收藏家。是吗？哦。
And Big Min says, oh, you know, how do you know that? No wonder you won the war. You know everything. And actually, interestingly, the orchid collection. So Big Min actually just devotes himself to orchid collecting after this. So he's fine. He's not shot. He's not put in the camp.
大明说：“哦，你知道的，你怎么知道的？难怪你们赢了战争。你们什么都知道。”事实上，有趣的是，关于兰花收藏——大明在这之后实际上就全身心投入到兰花收集当中了。所以他很好。他没有被枪决。他没有被送进集中营。
No. Does he get re-education centre? No, I don't think he's re-educated, interestingly. He's basically under house arrest in a villa where he looks at orchids and smiles to himself in the mirror and looks at his tooth. Well, meanwhile, his predecessor, President Tew. He's in Surrey. He's watching the Eton wall game. Yes. Or whatever. whatever yes both of them could have come to worse fates exactly you started
没有。他去接受再教育了吗？不，有趣的是，我想他并没有被重新教育。他基本上是被软禁在一栋别墅里，在那里赏兰花，对着镜子对自己微笑，看着自己的牙齿。好吧，与此同时，他的前任，阮文绍总统（President Thieu）。他在萨里。他正在观看伊顿公学墙球赛。是的。诸如此类。总之，是的。他们两个本可以落得更惨的下场。完全正确。你以詹姆斯·芬顿开始了
the first episode in this with james fenton didn't you tom and james fenton actually um the poet he actually goes back to the u.s embassy a few hours later to see what's going on and it's absolute and utter chaos and he actually does loot books from the embassy library well he's with a french businessman isn't he and the french businessman just kind of goes berserk so kind of grabbing everything that he can and uh and fenton joins in and you in your in your um in this book that i hope someone will will get out there fenton's gone there beside him a french businessman similarly swept up in the craze for booty picked up a dusty color portrait of a smiling man in a dark suit surrounded by his family to ambassador and mrs graham martin with appreciation
这一系列的第一集，对吧，汤姆？而诗人詹姆斯·芬顿实际上……几个小时后，他又回到了美国大使馆，想看看发生了什么，那里是一片绝对彻底的混乱。他甚至真的从大使馆图书馆里掠夺了图书。好吧，他和和一个法国商人在一起，对吧？那个法国商人简直有点精神失常了，疯狂地抓取他能拿的一切东西，然后芬顿也加入了进去。而你在你的书里——我希望有人能去读读这本书——芬顿就在他旁边，那个法国商人同样被战利品狂热冲昏了头脑，拿走了一幅满脸笑容的男子的尘土飞扬的彩色肖像画，画中男子身穿深色西装，被家人环绕。铭文上写着：“献给格雷厄姆·马丁大使及夫人，感谢他们为国家做出的服务——理查德·尼克松赠。”好吧，带着这个结局，西贡沦陷了。多米尼克，当我们回来时，也许我们可以谈谈这背后的长期影响。没问题。中场休息后再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将为你揭开娱乐行业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。
for their service to the nation read the inscription from richard nixon yeah well so on that note saigon has fallen and dominic when we come back perhaps we could talk about the long-term ramifications sure see you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
如果你想享受无广告音频、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场活动门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。多米尼克·桑布鲁克，那段声音当然是……你是水中的呼吸。你是我的河流。多米尼克·森布鲁克，那当然是《现代启示录》中的马龙·白兰度，这是越战和西贡沦陷后拍摄的一系列电影之一。你会想到这部电影和《猎鹿人》（The Deer Hunter）。我不会想到那个。我想《猎鹿人》和《现代启示录》是两部具有里程碑意义的电影……
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. That, Dominic Sandbrick, was, of course, You are the breath of the water. You are my river. That, Dominic Sembrick, was, of course, Marlon Brando in Apocalypse Now, one of a number of films that was made in the wake of the Vietnam War and the fall of Saigon. And you think of that and the deer hunter. I don't think of that. I suppose the deer hunter and I don't think of that well I suppose the deer hunter and apocalypse now the two kind of landmark films that were
它们是在越战之后拍摄的，是美国消化和试图应对创伤的方式。但在这之前，当我们谈到这一切对美国的影响时，也许我们应该看看越南发生了什么，南越人发生了什么。比如，所有那些未能从美国大使馆逃出来的人，他们怎么样了？他们会怎么样？他们会被围捕吗？他们会被枪决吗？他们会被重新教育吗？他们能逃脱吗？到底会发生什么？所以，好吧，从来没有人用过这样的朗读来开启关于南越命运的讨论，我认为这是公允的。相当不错。相当准确。但是，好吧，他们没有被枪决。
made in the way yes yeah the Vietnam war and kind of ways for America to process and try and come to terms with the trauma of what had happened. But before we come to the impact of all this on America, perhaps we should look at what happened to Vietnam, to the South Vietnamese. What happens to all, for instance, to all the people who have not managed to escape from the US embassy? What happens to them? Do they get rounded up? Do they get shot? Do they get re-educated? Do they get away? What happens? So, well, no one has ever introduced a discussion of the fate of South Vietnam with a reading like that, I think it's fair to say. Pretty good. Pretty accurate. But okay, they don't get shot.
所以这是一个有趣的现象。这不是红色高棉。不。所以我想这就是那段记述的价值所在，你在第一集里确实提到了柬埔寨。因为当时人们的预期相当具有世界末日般的色彩。
So this is an interesting thing. It's not Khmer Rouge. No. So I think that's what makes that valuable that you actually did mention Cambodia in episode one. Because the expectation, I think, at this point is quite apocalyptic. That they will all be apocalyptic that they will all be killed or that there will be some gigantic purge or whatever bloodbath yeah bloodbath there isn't really a bloodbath i mean i'm not saying there's nothing there undoubtedly are acts of
世界末日般的色彩，即他们都会被杀害，或者会发生某种巨大的清洗或血洗。血洗。其实并没有真正的血洗。我的意思是，我并不是说完全没有暴力，毫无疑问存在着暴力和恐怖的行为。这其实很难说，因为毕竟赢得那场战争的人今天仍然在统治着越南，或者至少是他们的意识形态传人。所以要弄清这一点有点困难。但据我们所知，大约有30万左右的人可能被送往了再教育营。你有时会看到高得多的数字，比如100万人。其中有些人被关了相当长的时间，对吧？是的。我的意思是，他们在那里呆了几十年。是的。所以其中一些再教育营
sort of violence and terror it's actually quite hard to tell because of course the people who won that war are still running vietnam to day, or at least they're ideological descendants. So it's slightly difficult to get a sense of this. But as far as we know, somewhere in the region of 300,000 people were probably sent to re-education camps. You do sometimes see figures that are much higher, so a million people. And some of them are there for quite a long time, aren't they? Yes. I mean, they're kind of there for decades. Yeah. So some of those re-education camps are
可能存在了大约20年。但这些营地，同样，与红色高棉的营地不太一样。红色高棉的营地，你一旦进去，就几乎没有机会再出来了。在这些营地里，你进去了，可能只是需要听上几天或几周非常枯燥的关于共产主义的讲座。最后你会被释放。另一方面……这有点像去一所英国大学上学。非常棒。非常棒，汤姆。非常棒。是的。就像去一所英国大学上学一样。轰。然而，你也有可能会遭到殴打。你可能会受到酷刑。据估计，可能有数千人，甚至可能是上万人，死在了这些营地里。另一方面，
probably there for about 20 years. But these, again, these are not quite like the Khmer Rouge's camps. So the Khmer Rouge's camps, you go in and there's a really very good chance you're not coming out again. In these camps, there's a chance that you might go and you'll just have to listen to days and days or weeks and weeks of very boring lectures about communism. And then eventually you'll be let out. On the other hand... A bit like going to a British university. Very good. Very good, Tom. Very good. Yes. Just like going to a British university. Boom. However, there is also a chance you could be beaten. You could be tortured. There are estimates that thousands of people may have, possibly even tens of thousands of people, may have died in the camps. On the other hand,
大概在那里呆了大约20年。但这些，再次说明，它们并不太像红色高棉的集中营。所以说红色高棉的集中营，你一旦进去，有极大的可能你就再也出不来了。而在这些营地里，你有可能会进去，然后不得不连续几天甚至几周听那些非常无聊的关于共产主义的讲座。然后最终你会被放出来。另一方面……有点像去上英国大学。非常好。非常好，汤姆。非常好。是的。就像去上英国大学一样。轰。然而，也有可能你会被殴打。你可能会受到酷刑。据估计，可能有数千人，甚至可能是数万人，在集中营里丧生。另一方面，
what we don't know is whether they died because they were beaten or they died of malnourishment. And actually, there are an awful lot of people dying in Vietnam of malnourishment at this point, because Vietnam has basically descended into an abyss, into a kind of economic and societal abyss. And America presumably is refusing to recognize the new government. So they've been cut out of the international trading system. Exactly. So if you think about- So quite like Afghanistan. Again, the analogy is there. Yeah. The Vietnamese economy is in utter tatters. They are dealing with literally millions of refugees, perhaps 10 million refugees. There are perhaps a million
我们不知道的是，他们是因为挨打而死，还是死于营养不良。事实上，当时有大量的人在越南死于营养不良，因为越南基本上已经坠入了深渊，坠入了一种经济和社会的深渊。而美国大概拒绝承认这个新政权。所以他们被排挤出了国际贸易体系。确实如此。因此，如果你回想一下——这有点像阿富汗。同样的，这种类比是存在的。是的。越南经济一团糟。他们正在应对数以百万计的难民，也许有1000万难民。可能有上百万
people who've been widowed because of the war. There are perhaps a million orphans. There are hundreds of thousands of people who have been injured because of the war. Millions of people with no jobs. Much of the countryside has been ravaged by chemical weapons or by bombing or by mines, all of that stuff. The Americans who had promised to pay billions of dollars in reconstruction aid as part of the Paris Peace Accords say, well, basically, because you violated the Paris Peace Accords in conquering the rest of the country, you are now liable for South Vietnam's debts to us. Okay. Yeah, that's punchy.
人因战争而成了寡妇。也许有上百万孤儿。有几十万人因战争而受伤。数以百万计的人失业。大片乡村遭到化学武器、轰炸或地雷的蹂躏，诸如此类。作为《巴黎和平协定》的一部分，曾承诺支付数十亿美元重建援助的美国人却表示，好吧，基本上，由于你们在征服该国其他地区时违反了《巴黎和平协定》，你们现在要对南越欠我们的债务负责。好吧。是的，这很有冲击力。
And because you're not going to pay, obviously, we're going to impose a trade embargo on you. Okay. So it's miserable it's miserable oh yes it's absolutely dire the interesting thing though is that the vietnamese regime is nothing like as repressive as the cambodian regime and actually the vietnamese regime ends up fighting the cambodian regime well because the very very witty comment that um cambodia becomes vietnam's vietnam right yeah because the vietnamese are there for 10 years they kind of get sucked into a kind of, they get bogged down. They do. They do indeed.
而且因为你们不会还钱，显然我们要对你们实施贸易禁令。好吧。所以这太惨了，简直惨透了。哦，是的，绝对是可怕至极。不过有趣的是，越南政权一点也不像柬埔寨政权那样压迫深重，事实上，越南政权最终与柬埔寨政权开战了，嗯，因为那个非常非常风趣的评论，呃，柬埔寨成了越南的越南，对吧？是的，因为越南人在那里呆了10年，他们有点被卷入了一种，陷入了泥潭。他们确实如此。他们确实陷入了泥潭。
Now, there are a lot of Vietnamese who, of course, have left and continue to leave. So in 1975. So these are the boat people. Yeah. So in 1975, there's about 100,000, 125,000 who've gone to America one way or another. So actually China then attacks Vietnam because of of vietnam intervening cambodia yeah i know i mean poor vietnamese i mean it's just one horror after another isn't it yeah so the boat people who you and i remember i mean i remember as a child watching john craven's news round yeah
现在，当然有很多越南人已经离开并将继续离开。所以在1975年。所以这些就是船民。是的。所以在1975年，大约有10万、12.5万人通过这样或那样的方式去了美国。所以中国随后攻击了越南，因为越南干涉了柬埔寨。是的，我知道，可怜的越南人，我的意思是这简直是一个又一个的噩梦，不是吗？是的，所以那些你我都还记得的船民，我的意思是，我小时候看约翰·克拉文的新闻圆桌节目时记得——是的
and it was always about the uh the vietnamese boat people 800 000 people got onto little boats or crammed onto really overcrowded, bigger boats and tried to get to... I mean, often they were heading for Indonesia or Malaysia or somewhere, or Thailand. But probably about 200,000 of them died, drowned in attempts to escape Vietnam. I mean, absolutely astronomical, terrifying figures. And actually, the fact that it's in Southeast Asia means that it's that little bit more distant from the kind of particularly European kind of consciousness, because if that had happened closer to- Well, in the Channel, for instance. I mean, imagine, whereas now it's largely forgotten. Most of our British listeners
而且总是关于呃越南船民。80万 人登上小船，或者挤在真正超载的大船上，试图到达……我的意思是，他们通常的目标是印度尼西亚、马来西亚或某个地方，或者泰国。但其中可能有大约20万人死于试图逃离越南的溺水事故。我的意思是，绝对是天文数字，极其可怕的数字。事实上，身处东南亚意味着它距离那种特别欧洲式的意识形态稍微遥远了一点，因为如果这件事发生在更接近——嗯，比如英吉利海峡。我的意思是，想象一下，而现在它基本上被遗忘了。我们大多数英国听众
will probably have forgotten all about this. When the boat people reach safety and they're heading for Thailand, aren't they? Is that right? Yeah. When they get there, are they staying in Thailand or are they going on to America? Well, the dream is to go to America. Does the American government, does their sense of responsibility and guilt lead them to giving visas more readily to South Vietnamese? Yes. So about 300,000 Vietnamese moved to America in the late 70s and early 80s. I mean, it's a very, very large movement of people.
大概都已经把这忘得精光了。当船民到达安全地带，他们正前往泰国，是这样吗？是的。当他们到达那里时，他们是留在泰国还是继续前往美国？嗯，梦想是去美国。美国政府，他们的责任感和负罪感是否促使他们更爽快地向南越人发放签证？是的。因此，在70年代末和80年代初，大约有30万越南人移居美国。我的意思是，这是一个非常非常巨大的人口流动。
But I think what's interesting is Gerald Ford, I mean, Ford went to Congress to get aid for the Vietnamese refugees in 1975. And Congress initially said, no, would you believe? And Ford went back again, was really cross about it, and went back again and did manage to get the aid through. But it's actually really remarkable how America is a country that has generally been very welcoming to waves of refugees. I mean, I know we can sort of find things to criticize, but by Western standards, generally, the United States has been
但我觉得有趣的是杰拉尔德·福特，福特曾在1975年向国会为越南难民争取援助。而国会最初竟然说不，你敢信？福特再次前往，对此真的很生气，又去了一次，最终设法让援助方案通过了。但事实上，美国这个通常对难民潮非常欢迎的国家，其表现真的很引人注目。我的意思是，我知道我们可以挑出一些值得批评的地方，但按西方标准来看，总的来说，美国一直是
very hospitable. By and large, the polls show that people were very, very ambivalent about admitting the Vietnamese. So there are huge sort of little panics about the vietnamese bringing disease in 1975 in nice phil yes a place called nice phil in florida where where people turn out not to be very nice yeah nice phil florida exactly so there's more than a thousand refugees at eglon air force base and uh eight out of ten local people said they didn't want them there lots of people said they won't cut their hair. They won't let them buy drinks. They won't do all this sort of thing.
非常热情好客的。总的来说，民意调查显示，人们对接纳越南人表现得非常非常矛盾。因此，在1975年，人们对越南人带来疾病产生了巨大的一些恐慌，在佛罗里达州一个叫尼斯维尔的好地方，是的，佛罗里达州的尼斯维尔，那里的当地人结果并不是那么“好”——是的，尼斯维尔，佛罗里达州，完全没错。所以埃格林空军基地有1万多名难民，而且呃，十分之八的当地人表示他们不希望那些人在那里。许多人说他们不会剪头发。不让他们买饮料。他们不肯做诸如此类的事。
I think a lot of that is as a projection. There's a feeling of humiliation of they're sick of the issue of Vietnam. And actually what's really interesting is they blame. So seeing Vietnamese people. Yeah. Seeing Vietnamese people, it just reminds them of everything they want to forget. Do you think that's it? I think there's that.
我认为这很大程度上是一种投射。有一种羞辱感，他们对越南问题已经厌烦透顶。事实上，真正有趣的是他们把矛头指向了——所以看到越南人。是的。看到越南人，只会让他们想起所有他们想要忘记的事情。你觉得是这样吗？我觉得有这方面原因。
And I think there's a lot of Americans who blame at the time, maybe not now, but at the time, their instinct is to blame the South Vietnamese themselves for having lost, for having run away, for having sucked us in, our boys into this fight. And then our boys lost. It was all terribly corrupt over there. And then the South Vietnamese themselves lost and ran away. We tried to help them, but they didn't want to be helped, all this sort of thing. And it's, yeah, there's a sort of, there is an ugly side to it.
而且我认为当时有很多美国人把责任归咎于南越人本身——现在可能不会了，但在当时，他们的本能是将失败归咎于南越人自己，怪他们战败，怪他们逃跑，怪他们把我们的人、把我们的小伙子们拖进了这场战斗。然后我们的小伙子们失败了。那里到处都极其腐败。然后南越人自己失败了却逃跑了。我们试图帮助他们，但他们却不想被帮助，诸如此类。而且，是的，这其中有一种丑陋的一面。
Okay, so that opens up the much broader question of how America kind of synthesizes what has happened. Is it about burying the memory? Is it about going into a kind of cultural national therapy and of course there's a very very broad range of responses to it so if people you know in the government kissinger and so on are traumatized by this so equally on the anti-war section yeah the humiliation of saigon is seen as a you know. People have festivals and things, don't they? It's absolutely mind-boggling to me, actually, this. So at Central Park, New York, on the 11th
好吧，这就引出了一个更广泛的问题：美国是如何综合看待所发生的事情的？这关乎掩埋记忆吗？这关乎进入某种文化和国家治疗吗？当然，对此的反应有着非常非常广泛的跨度。因此，如果政府中的人们（比如基辛格等人）对此感到创伤，那么在反战派别中同样如此。萨贡的羞辱被视为一种（你知道的）——人们举行庆祝活动之类的，不是吗？实际上，这对我来说简直难以置信。因此，在纽约中央公园，1975年5月
of May, 1975, plays host to a rally of some 50,000 people, many of whom are anti-war activists who have gathered to celebrate the North Vietnamese victory. And they are the sort of anti-war folk singers and stuff who are singing their old ballads. There are two Democratic Congresswomen, local Democratic Congresswomen, Bella Abzug and Elizabeth Holtzman, Pete Seeger, Paul Simon, people like that. All the lads.
11日，举办了一场约有5万人的集会，其中许多人是反战活动人士，他们聚集在一起庆祝北越的胜利。他们是那种反战民谣歌手之类的人，正在唱着他们的老民歌。有两位民主党女国会议员，当地的民主党女国会议员贝拉·阿布扎格和伊丽莎白·霍尔茨曼，还有皮特·西格、保罗·西蒙这样的人。全都是这些大咖。
It's a really weird thing. A lot of people there are just celebrating. They are delighted that South Vietnam has been defeated. Well, because they would say it's not America that's been defeated, but it's the warmongering militarists who have seized control of America. They would indeed. They absolutely would. And maybe some people listening to this podcast will say that now. I wouldn't want to be making that argument to somebody who's about to spend 20 years in a re-education camp, who might say,
这真是一件诡异的事。那里有很多人只是在庆祝。他们为南越被打败而感到高兴。嗯，因为他们会说，被打败的不是美国，而是夺取了美国控制权的那些穷兵黩武的军国主义者。他们确实会这么说。他们绝对会这么说。也许听这个播客的一些人现在也会这么说。我可不想把这种观点强加给一个即将在再教育营度过20年、可能会说“听着，
listen, we believed in you and my entire family have been incarcerated and their lives have been blighted by you. I mean, I think it's not a moment you could absolutely oppose the war. You could oppose the war with every fibre of your being and still regard the fall of Saigon and South Vietnam as a tragic moment rather than one for celebration, I would have said. Right. But I mean, the assumption about Vietnam, it seems to me, has been that for Americans, it's a bit like what the First World War is for the British, that it's a doomed war, a foolish war, shouldn't have been fought. Basically, both sides were as bad as the other. Is that an accurate reflection of the historical reality, do you think? And the reason that I ask is to go back to those echoes of General Gordon. General Gordon was a man who was committed to destroying the slave trade.
我们信任过你，而我的整个家庭都遭到监禁，我的人生被你们毁了”这样的人。我的意思是，这并不是一个你可以绝对反对战争的时刻。我会说，你可以用你全身心的每一根纤维去反对战争，但仍然把西贡和南越的陷落视为一个悲剧时刻，而不是一个值得庆祝的时刻。对吧。但是，关于越南的假设，在我看来一直是：对美国人来说，它有点像第一次世界大战对英国人的意义——这是一场注定失败的战争、一场愚蠢的战争、本不该打的战争。基本上，双方都一样烂。你认为这是对历史现实的准确反映吗？我问这个是为了回到戈登将军的回响。戈登将军是一个致力于消灭奴隶贸易的人。
He felt that in taking a stand against the Mahdi, he was on the right side of history, if you want to put it like that. With Vietnam, there are two very ideologically committed groups of people in America who both feel that they're on the right side of history. Those who are opposing the war, those who are supporting the war. When the war finishes, where do those assumptions go? So people on the left and people on the right, or does it just, I mean, because this is very much the impression I get from Apocalypse Now and Deer Hunter, is that ultimately the idea that on either side, there was a right side of history completely goes up in smoke, goes up in napalm, you might say.
他觉得在对抗马赫迪时，如果可以这样说的话，他站在了历史正确的一边。对于越南，美国有两个意识形态坚定的群体，他们都觉得自己站在了历史正确的一边。那些反对战争的人，那些支持战争的人。战争结束后，这些假设都去哪儿了？所以左翼和右翼的人，或者它只是——我的意思是，因为这很像我从《现代启示录》和《猎鹿人》中得到的印象，那就是最终“无论哪一方，都存在历史正确的一边”这种想法完全化为乌有，你甚至可以说化为凝固汽油弹付之一炬。
But the whole thing was just a moral catastrophe. The Viet Cong, the South Vietnamese, the Marines, everybody was morally compromised. There was no right side of history there. Well, that's a really complicated question. So let's start with the people at the top. So Henry Kissinger is the most obvious one because he's been the person who's been, I suppose, presiding over the war for the last six years or so. Kissinger writes a paper, Gerald Ford's request on the lessons of Vietnam. He says we were always on the right side of history. He says our intervention in Vietnam saved Indonesia from falling to communism and the whole of Asia would have gone and we preserved
整件事只是一场道德灾难。越共、南越人、海军陆战队员，所有人在道德上都沦陷了。那里根本没有什么历史正确的一边。嗯，这是一个非常复杂的问题。所以让我们从高层开始。亨利·基辛格是最明显的例子，因为他可以说是过去六年左右一直主持这场战争的人。基辛格应杰拉尔德·福特的要求写了一篇关于越南教训的论文。他说我们一直站在历史正确的一边。他说我们在越南的干预拯救了印度尼西亚，使其免于落入共产主义之手，否则整个亚洲都会沦陷，而且我们保住了
some sort of US presence in Asia. I believe our efforts militarily, diplomatically, and politically were not in vain. We paid a high price, but we gained 10 years in time. We changed what then appeared to be an overwhelming momentum. But he would say that, right? Well, he would say that. And I don't think most historians would now agree with him. I think most historians would say that's nonsense, that actually Indonesia was not going to go communist as a result of a domino theory, that actually the domino theory was nonsense, that there was no communist monolith because as proved by the facts, as we said, these countries all started fighting each other, Cambodia, Vietnam, China.
美国在亚洲的某种存在。我相信我们在军事、外交和政治上的努力并非徒劳。我们付出了沉重的代价，但我们赢得了十年的时间。我们扭转了当时看来势不可挡的势头。但他当然会这么说，对吧？嗯，他会这么说。而且我认为大多数历史学家现在不会同意他的看法。我认为大多数历史学家会说那是胡扯，实际上印度尼西亚并不会因为多米诺骨牌理论而变成共产主义国家，实际上多米诺骨牌理论是无稽之谈，根本没有什么共产主义铁板一块，因为事实证明，正如我们所说，这些国家开始互相征伐——柬埔寨、越南、中国。
We had Andrew Preston, a great historian at Cambridge University, who's written a lot about Vietnam on our podcast. And he said, it was the wrong war to fight, wrong time, the wrong place. There is no right side of history argument for it, really. I mean, remember, the communists are still running Vietnam to this day in 2023. But they're very capitalist communists, aren't they? Capitalist communists, right. They changed tack. Their policies were a disaster. They changed tack completely in the middle of the 1980s, rather like the Chinese, to embrace capitalism.
我们邀请了剑桥大学的伟大历史学家安德鲁·普雷斯顿上我们的播客，他写了很多关于越南的文章。他说，这是一场打错了的战争，时间不对，地点不对。它真的没有什么“站在历史正确的一边”的论据。请记住，直到2023年今天，共产党人依然在统治着越南。但他们是非常资本主义的共产党人，对吧？资本主义的共产党人，没错。他们改变了方针。他们的政策曾是一场灾难。他们在20世纪80年代中期彻底改变了方针，就像中国一样，拥抱了资本主义。
And in fact, what they now have, a lot of people say, is the worst of capitalism and the worst of communism, but also a very high rate of economic growth. And a very successful COVID policy. Really? What did they do? Well, none of them got COVID. Right, okay.
事实上，很多人说他们现在拥有的是最糟糕的资本主义和最糟糕的共产主义，但也伴随着非常高的经济增长率。还有一个非常成功的防疫政策。真的吗？他们做了什么？嗯，他们谁都没感染新冠。好吧，原来是这样。
But they've got also a thriving tourist industry, interestingly. Yeah. Anyway, so I think the arguments for and against the Vietnam War, both left and right, they both become kind of rolled into this general sense of American victimhood, actually. So you mentioned the deer hunter and indeed Apocalypse Now. The deer hunter is the best example of that. Of the first wave of Vietnam films, that's Coming Home and Go Tell the Spartans and The Deer Hunter.
不过有趣的是，他们也有一个蓬勃发展的旅游业。是的。无论如何，所以我觉得支持和反对越南战争的论点，无论是左翼还是右翼，其实都变成了一种对美国受害者情结的普遍感受。所以你提到了《猎鹿人》以及《现代启示录》。《猎鹿人》就是最好的例子。在第一波越南战争电影中，那是《归家》、《去告诉斯巴达人》和《猎鹿人》。
They all come out at that same time, 1978 or so. The Deer Hunter is the most successful, great triumph at the Oscars. Anyone who's seen it remembers Christopher Walken and Robert De Niro, the Russian roulette and all that sort of stuff. And that film presents Americans as being innocents who have been sort of lured into this terrible inferno inhabited by these barbaric and cruel and savage people. So all the Vietnamese are shown in the film as just unbelievably corrupt. And I mean, lots of people said at the time they said it was a very racist film. Yeah.
它们都在同一时期上映，大约在1978年左右。《猎鹿人》是最成功的一部，在奥斯卡上大获全胜。看过的每个人都记得克里斯托弗·沃肯和罗伯特·德尼罗，俄罗斯轮盘赌以及所有那些乱七八糟的场景。这部电影把美国人表现为无辜者，他们被诱入了这个由这些野蛮、残酷和凶残的人所居住的可怕炼狱中。因此，片中的所有越南人都被表现得极其腐败。我的意思是，当时很多人说这是一部非常种族主义的电影。是的。
The Americans are all basically decent people who have been corrupted well you've seen them for an hour haven't you kind of hanging out in their steel town right exactly in pennsylvania or wherever it is um going to weddings and drinking beer and yeah being great pals and having this they're all they're ethnic ruthenians aren't they in uh so they're kind of ukrainians in the deer hunter so they go to vietnam and they descend into the heart of darlin so it's not dissimilar to the sort of trajectory of general kurtz or of the horror the horror yeah of martin sheen's character as uh marlon brando would put it yes i wondered if we get marlon brando again i should never have mentioned apocalypse now
美国人基本上都是正派人，却被腐败了——嗯，你看了他们一个小时了，对吧，他们在他们位于宾夕法尼亚或其他什么地方的钢铁小镇里闲逛，对吧，去参加婚礼，喝啤酒，是的，做着好哥们，享受着这种生活——他们都是民族鲁塞尼亚人，对吧，在《猎鹿人》里他们有点像乌克兰人——所以他们去了越南，然后陷入了黑暗的核心，所以这和库尔兹将军的轨迹或恐怖的恐怖（正如马龙·白兰度所说的那样，马丁·谢恩角色的恐怖恐怖）没有什么不同，是的，我一直在想我们是否还会提到马龙·白兰度，我本不该提《现代启示录》的。
and i think that sense is actually the one that becomes the more powerful, even than the arguments about whether or not it was right or wrong to go into. So the argument is basically, we are still a decent and innocent people who through a series of terrible blunders were dragged into this kind of maelstrom. And we've been terribly scarred as a result of it. Certainly the late 70s, I would say that was the presiding, the overwhelming feeling. But also, of course, there was a massive feeling of humiliation. Through no fault of his own, Jimmy Carter becomes associated with that in the late 70s. Yes. And so you could argue, couldn't you, that a lot of American attitudes to foreign policy since the 70s, there's been a kind of conflicted response to what lessons you should learn. And it seems to me that they're summed up by, ironically, the figure of Tom Cruise.
而且我认为这种感觉实际上变得更加强大，甚至超过了关于介入是否正确或错误的争论。所以这个论点基本上是：我们仍然是一个正派和无辜的人民，通过一系列可怕的失误被拖入了这种漩涡。结果我们受到了可怕的创伤。当然在70年代后期，我会说那是占主导地位的、压倒一切的感觉。但当然，也有巨大的羞辱感。在70年代后期，吉米·卡特在毫无过错的情况下与这种羞辱感联系在了一起。是的。所以你可以争辩说，不是吗，自70年代以来，美国对外政策的许多态度，对应该吸取什么教训一直有一种相互矛盾的反应。在我看来，讽刺的是，这可以由汤姆·克鲁斯这个人物来总结。
So Tom Cruise, all action hero, but one of the roles for which he was most lauded as an actor was playing Ronkovich, who was a Marine who went to Vietnam, came back. I think he lost both his legs, didn't he? Yeah, he ends up in a wheelchair. Ends up in a wheelchair and becomes a very prominent peace campaigner. And Tom Cruise stars in the film of his life, Born on the Fourth of July. And that articulates the idea. I suppose it's ultimately, it's an isolationist idea that America has no business going in, poking its noses into the business of other countries, but also that if you do that, awful things will happen. So it's good for America,
所以汤姆·克鲁斯，全能动作英雄，但他作为演员获得最高赞誉的角色之一是在《生于七月四日》中扮演罗恩·科维奇，他是一名去过越南的海军陆战队员，后来回来了。我想他失去了双腿，对吧？是的，他最终坐上了轮椅。最终坐上了轮椅，并成为了一名非常著名的和平活动家。汤姆·克鲁斯主演了根据他生平改编的电影《生于七月四日》。这表达了这样一种观点。我想这最终是一种孤立主义观点，认为美国不应该插手、把鼻子伸进其他国家的事务中，但也认为如果你那样做了，可怕的事情就会发生。所以这对美国有益，
it's good for the world, would be the attitude. But Tom Cruise has also starred in Top Gun and Top Gun 2. And Top Gun 2 is all about going and blasting up whatever it is he blasts in Top Gun 2, that America has a duty to get out there and kick Commie Butt. And this idea that a war will enable America to redeem its honour, to get over Vietnam, that's also been a kind of enduring narrative. So it's there in Rambo, famously, in the 80s. So Rambo's all about that. But it was also there in the arguments for the first Gulf War, for the second Gulf War, even in Afghanistan. But all of those wars have basically, it seemed to me, kind of confirmed the lesson of Vietnam, that the age for imperial adventures abroad perhaps is over. Perhaps it always was, that even the technology and firepower of the world's greatest superpower is ultimately unable to resist the same kind of forces that led to the doom of General
对世界有益，这大概就是这种态度。但汤姆·克鲁斯还主演了《壮志凌云》和《壮志凌云2》。《壮志凌云2》讲的就是去轰炸他在《壮志凌云2》里轰炸的那些东西，美国有责任走出去狠狠踢共产主义分子的屁股。这种认为战争能让美国挽回荣誉、走出越南阴影的想法，也一直是一种持久的叙事。所以在80年代的《第一滴血》中就很出名。所以《第一滴血》全都是关于这个的。但它也存在于第一次海湾战争、第二次海湾战争甚至阿富汗战争的争论中。但在我看来，所有这些战争基本上都印证了越南战争的教训——海外进行帝国冒险的时代或许已经结束了。或许它从来就没存在过，甚至连世界上超级大国的技术和火力，最终也无法抵御导致戈登将军或喀布尔英国人走向毁灭的同类力量。
Gordon or the British in Kabul. Well, that's what I was about to say. You mentioned General Gordon. What the Americans do with Vietnam, I would say, is exactly what the British do with their own defeats in the 19th century. So General Gordon is the kind of... He stands in in a weird way for the kind of Captain Willard in Apocalypse Now or the Christopher Walken, Robert De Niro kind of
嗯，这正是我要说的。你提到了戈登将军。我要说的是，美国人对越南的做法，跟英国人在19世纪遭遇各自失败时的做法如出一辙。所以戈登将军在某种奇怪的意义上，就代表了《现代启示录》中的威拉德上尉，或是《猎鹿人》中的克里斯托弗·沃肯、罗伯特·德尼罗那样的
characters in The Deer Hunter. So General Gordon in the British imagination is the Christian hero, the saint or the martyr, who has gone off to this terrible place to do his best and has fallen victim to the exotic foreign savage passions of this far off land you know that sort of heart of darkness idea that you were talking about so that becomes very pronounced in america but that's something that's old that's something the british thought is what they thought after the retreat from kabul and so um apocalypse now is based literally on heart of darkness i mean it's based on conrad's story of belgian imperialism in the Congo.
角色。因此，戈登将军在英国人的想象中是基督教英雄、圣徒或烈士，他前往这个可怕的地方尽了最大努力，却成了这片遥远土地上异国野蛮凶残激情的牺牲品——你知道你刚才谈到的那种黑暗之心。所以这在美国变得非常明显，但这是老一套，是英国人在从喀布尔撤退后所持的想法，所以……嗯，《现代启示录》字面意义上就是基于《黑暗之心》拍的，我的意思是它基于康拉德关于比利时帝国主义在刚果的故事。
Exactly. What happens to America with Vietnam, actually, I would say, a really good way to understand it is to say it's actually really very similar to the British attitudes to empire in the second half of the 19th century, which is there are people who regard it as you touch it and you are tainted. You know that this is the dark heart of darkness, that you can tell a story about British involvement with the rest of the world in the second half of the 19th century, that is a saga of defeats and humiliations. Or you can tell it as one that is a saga of heroic stands against the odds, you know, rorks drift, all of that sort of stuff. I think it's not that the age of imperialism is over, but I think that dynamic or that conversation, are we victims? Are we liberators? Are we innocents abroad? Should we stay out of all foreign entanglements? I mean, all of the things that people are saying in the
没错。越南对美国的影响，实际上，我觉得理解它的一个很好的方法是说，它其实非常类似于19世纪下半叶英国人对帝国的态度，也就是总有人认为只要你碰了它，你就会被玷污。你知道，这是黑暗的黑暗核心，你可以讲述一个关于英国在19世纪下半叶与世界其他地方纠缠的故事，那是一部失败与羞辱的传奇。或者你可以把它讲成一部在逆境中进行英雄抵抗的传奇——罗克渡口战役，诸如此类。我认为并不是帝国主义时代结束了，而是那种动态或对话——我们是受害者吗？我们是解放者吗？我们是初来乍到的无辜者吗？我们应该置身于所有海外纠缠之外吗？我的意思是，人们在
1970s, 80s, 90s and onwards in America, they're not saying anything that people weren't saying a hundred years earlier in Britain. Yeah. And again, thinking of fictional treatments of it, the idea that to go abroad into some kind of imperial heart of darkness is damaging and that that damage can then be re-imported back into the imperial metropolis. So if you think of Taxi Driver, the Robert De Niro character is a damaged veteran. And you think of all the Sherlock Holmes stories where sinister figures from abroad come back and are purloining jewels or have brought people with blowpipes or whatever.
1970年代、80年代、90年代及以后在美国所说的一切，和一百年前在英国人们所说的话如出一辙。是的。再次想到对它的虚构处理，即前往某种帝国主义的黑暗之心是有害的，而这种伤害随后又可以被重新输入到帝国都会中。如果你想想《出租车司机》，罗伯特·德尼罗饰演的角色就是一个受创伤的老兵。想想所有的《福尔摩斯》故事，其中来自海外的阴险人物回来偷窃珠宝，或者带着吹箭筒之类的人。
It's the same kind of idea, isn't it? Oh, it is. Absolutely. Well, I mean, Dr. Watson is an injured veteran. Yeah. Remember, he's got his limp from Afghanistan. But in both cases, it's absolutely about the imperial power. power. It's about the British. It's about the Americans. It's very much not about the Afghans or the Vietnamese. Agreed.
这完全是同一种想法，不是吗？哦，确实如此。嗯，我的意思是，华生医生就是一个受伤的老兵。是的。记住，他因为阿富汗之战而一瘸一拐。但在两起案件中，这绝对都关乎帝国强权。这关乎英国人。这关乎美国人。这绝对不关乎阿富汗人或越南人。完全同意。
I mean, they're kind of peripheral characters whose role is to embody the heart of darkness. Oh, you're absolutely right. So this is the criticism that people made of The Deer Hunter at the time. Apocalypse Now, which is probably the single best known vietnam war film do any vietnamese characters even speak no they just kind of you know they're there to be napalmed to the sound of agner i mean the protagonist and the antagonist are both american uh martin sheen and marlon brando although of course marlon brando character is also british because he's modeled on colon Colonel Kurtz. Is Colonel Kurtz British? Maybe he's not. Willard is certainly British.
我的意思是，他们有点像边缘人物，他们的角色就是体现黑暗之心。哦，你绝对是对的。所以这就是当时人们对《猎鹿人》的批评。在《现代启示录》（可能是最著名的越战电影）中，有任何越南角色开口说话吗？没有，他们只是……你知道的，他们只是伴随着瓦格纳的音乐被凝固汽油弹轰炸的存在。我的意思是，主角和对立面都是美国人——马丁·谢恩和马龙·白兰度，尽管当然马龙·白兰度的角色也是英国人，因为他是以库尔兹上校为原型的。库尔兹上校是英国人吗？也许他不是。威拉德绝对是英国人。
Willard is Marlow, isn't he? Yeah. So it's a story about American Vietnam that is filtered through the story about the Belgian Congo written by a British Polish novelist. I mean, just extraordinary sort of series of filters. But none of those filters are actually Vietnamese orese or congolese no exactly right so we've got loads of american listeners i know to the rest is history many of whom will have read a lot of the books about uh by tim o'brien or philip computer or whoever about vietnam about the americans of vietnam they've seen loads of
威拉德就是马洛，对吧？是的。所以这是一个通过英国波兰籍小说家关于比利时刚果的故事过滤出来的关于美国越南的故事。我的意思是，这是一系列非常奇特的过滤器。但所有这些过滤器里面实际上都没有越南人或刚果人。哦，完全正确。所以我们有大量的美国听众，我知道《历史的休止符》的听众也是如此，其中许多人读过很多关于越南的图书——比如蒂姆·奥布里安、菲利普·卡普托或其他任何人关于美国在越南的著作，他们看过无数
the films but actually when you think of it and how many of those things is there even a named vietnamese character i mean that's the weird thing that's... I mean, it's actually even been missing from the two podcasts that we've done, Tom, to a large extent. We've had some Vietnamese characters, but most of our characters have been American. We had Big... What's his name? Big Min.
电影。但实际上，仔细想想，在其中多少作品里甚至有一个具名的越南角色？我的意思是，这才是奇怪的地方……我的意思是，汤姆，在很大程度上，它甚至在我们做过的这两期播客中也缺失了。我们有一些越南角色，但我们的大多数角色都是美国人。我们有大……叫什么来着？大明。
Big Min. We had President Tu with his older Tony and son. But no, it's a really, really interesting... Right. So we haven't quoted from any of the Vietnamese who were outside the compound of the US embassy trying to get in. No, no, we haven't. And Ken Burns does that to an extent in his film, doesn't he? He has a few Vietnamese interviewees. Well, he has Viet Cong, he has South Vietnamese. Yeah, he does. He does. He absolutely does. And I think there's much more, actually, in Vietnam historiography more generally, I think in the last 10 years or or so there's been a much bigger move to incorporate to de-center to de-center well i mean but the
大明。我们有带着老陶尼和儿子的阮文绍总统。不，这真是一个非常非常有趣的……没错。所以我们没有引用任何在美军大使馆大院外试图闯进去的越南人的话。不，不，我们没有。肯·伯恩斯在他的电影中在某种程度上做到了这一点，不是吗？他采访了一些越南人。嗯，他有越共，也有南越人。是的，他确实有。他确实有。绝对有。而且我认为在越南史学中实际上还有更多，我认为在过去10年左右的时间里，有一个更大的趋势去整合、去解中心化——去解中心化……嗯，我的意思是，
funny thing is vietnam is the center well to de-center the the american right to de-center the american experience but on america so where i think it works with america and i think the ultimate effect is actually i think to me as a as a non-American, one of the interesting things about American politics since, let's say, the 1970s is that it's become, I would argue, more overtly nationalistic and less internationalistic, if you know what I mean. So for Eisenhower, Truman, Kennedy, whoever, or Nixon, in fact, they saw America as the leader of a Cold War alliance. And America's place in the world was enormously important to them. And I think what has obviously become more and more pronounced in the last 20,
有趣的是，越南才是中心。——去解中心化美式视角，去解中心化美国的经验。但聚焦于美国。所以，我认为它对美国的作用，以及在我看来作为非美国人，自20世纪70年代以来美国政治最有趣的事情之一，可以说是它变得更加公开地具有民族主义色彩，而国际主义色彩有所减弱，如果你懂我的意思的话。因此，对艾森豪威尔、杜鲁门、肯尼迪或任何人（实际上包括尼克松）来说，他们将美国视为冷战联盟的领导者。美国在世界上的地位对他们来说极其重要。而我认为在过去20、
30 years, exemplified by Donald Trump and his America First stuff, is the sort of shining city on a hill that is not necessarily open to the rest of the world. Well, and Trump didn't go to Vietnam. No, he didn't go to Vietnam. He had a bony spur in his foot or something. He did. And do you want to know what Trump said about Vietnam? I remember what he said about McCain, that he preferred his heroes not to have been taken prisoner. He said he had his own personal Vietnam.
30年里，以唐纳德·特朗普及其“美国优先”口号为代表的东西，显然变得越来越明显，那就是那种不一定对世界其余部分开放的“山巅之城”。嗯，而且特朗普没有去越南。不，他没有去越南。他的脚上长了骨刺什么的。他确实长了。你想知道特朗普是怎么谈论越南的吗？我记得他是怎么评价麦凯恩的，说他宁愿自己的英雄没有被俘虏。他说他有他自己的个人越南。
He said, we had our own Vietnam. It's called the dating game. Did you know this? He said dating was perilous because of the risk of sexually transmitted diseases. I've been so lucky. It's my own personal Vietnam. I feel like a great and very brave soldier. And the interesting thing about that, of course, is that it did Trump no harm whatsoever.
他说，我们有我们自己的越南。这叫做约会游戏。你知道这个吗？他说约会很危险，因为有感染性病的风险。我太幸运了。这是我自己的个人越南。我觉得自己像个伟大而非常勇敢的士兵。当然，有趣的是，这根本没有对特朗普造成任何伤害。
No, it didn't. I think because the Vietnam War, for a lot of people, is ancient history now. One person we did do a podcast about very recently, Ronald Reagan, he gave a speech in 1980 that's probably largely forgotten now, but he argued that Vietnam was the right war, a noble cause. And that did him no harm at all. I think a lot of Americans wanted to hear. Don't forget, a lot of Americans always supported the war. They might have had sort of mixed feelings about it and not been terribly happy about it. Pollsters often used to say, there's only one thing that Americans hate more than the Vietnam War, and that's the anti-war
没有，确实没有。我想这是因为对很多人来说，越南战争现在已经是古代历史了。我们最近做过一期播客的一个人——罗纳德··里根，他在1980年发表了一场现在可能已经被大体遗忘的演讲，但他辩称越南是一场正确的战争，是一项崇高的事业。这对他一点伤害也没有。我想很多美国人很想听到这个。别忘了，许多美国人一直支持这场战争。他们可能对它有着某种复杂的情感，而且并不是特别高兴。民意调查专家过去常常说，美国人只有一件事比讨厌越战更讨厌，那就是反战
movement. So I think Americans always had conflicted feelings about Vietnam. And actually, one of the things that Reagan offered was an opportunity to put Vietnam behind them. And there were things like the, I mean, people often said about things like the invasion of Grenada. I mean, it's such a sideshow by comparison, but that it made Americans feel good about themselves. They could actually get something done without being embroiled in this agonising conflict. Well, thank you, Dominic. And thank you, everyone, for listening.
运动。所以我认为美国人对越南一直有着矛盾的情感。事实上，里根提供的事情之一就是一个把越南抛在脑后的机会。还有一些事情，我的意思是人们经常谈论诸如入侵格林纳达之类的事情——相比之下这只是一场微不足道的插曲，但它让美国人自我感觉良好。他们终于能干成点事，而不必卷入这种痛苦的冲突中了。谢谢你，多米尼克。也谢谢大家的聆听。
A gripping, terrifying, sobering story. Brilliantly told. May I say it to order force? Oh, Tom, that's very nice. Do you not think it's so like the Kabul thing last year? Yeah, I do. I mean, it's impossible to resist the uh the echoes are very clear and and if there's a lesson the truth is when you go in
一个引人入胜、惊心动魄、发人深省的故事。讲得太精彩了。请允许我这么说，简直力量感十足。哦，汤姆，你太客气了。你不觉得这太像去年喀布尔的事情了吗？是的，我是这么觉得的。我的意思是，根本无法抗拒呃——那些回响非常清晰，如果说有什么教训的话，那就是事实一旦你深入其中
it is really really really hard to get out and i don't mean just stop intervening i mean it is physically hard to withdraw from the i mean how do you do it when you've got all these people who are relying on you but the other lesson you might draw is actually in the long run it's quite easy to get out because you have no choice. Yeah, I suppose so. The danger is you draw a lesson, which is basically just, we sit on our hands and we're isolationists. We never do anything at all. And the trouble is people have always sought since the end of the Vietnam war, they've looked for a formula that will say, oh, this intervention is fine. You know, Bosnia, Kosovo or something,
要抽身是难乎其难，我指的不仅仅是停止干预，我是说在物理上很难从——我的意思是，当你有这么多人都在依赖你时，你怎么能一走了之呢？但你可能得到的另一个教训是，从长远来看，抽身其实挺容易的，因为你别无选择。是的，我想是的。危险在于你吸取了一个教训，基本上就是我们袖手旁观，我们成了孤立主义者。我们什么都不做。麻烦的是，自越战结束以来，人们一直在寻找一个公式，说“哦，这次干预没问题，比如波斯尼亚、科索沃之类的，但那次干预不行”。而事实上从来没有一个完美的公式。历史的教训就是历史没有任何教训。我们已经说过无数次了。是的。带着这个深刻之极的感悟，我们要向大家深情道别。好的，来自汤姆、我以及他那糟糕透顶的马龙·白兰度的道别。再见。
but this intervention is not fine. And there actually never is a neat formula. The lesson of history is that there are no lessons. We've said that so many times. Yeah. On that profound, profound note, we will bid you a very fond farewell. Yes, farewell from Tom, from me, and from his awful, awful Marlon Brando. Goodbye.
（无对话，此处原字幕为结束或空白）
Bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. and a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。感谢收听《历史的休止符》。如需获取独家节目、抢先收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com。网址是 restishistorypod.com。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目和抢先收听…… 本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。